يا دان دين يا داني دين يا دان يا داندين
يلا يا دانين يا داندين يا دان يا
داندين شمس الحلال عند الفري زي سحايب من
مطر ليله را منها سواى
والارض مرحبا والف تحيه من ارض تعبق
برائحه البخور من سلطنه تداعب البحر
والخليج وتنهض قبل كل العرب لاستقبال
الشمس كل صباح اهلا بكم في اسرار
[موسيقى]
عمان العبار سرا في غبه بحر يحمل الكنوز
مجد وذهب
ما تعرفونه باسم اللباني او البخور بفضله
كان العرب جنوب الجزيره العربيه من اغنى
شعوب الارض في القرن الاول ميلادي من ابرز
مواطنه سلطنه عمان في هذه الحلقه اكتشفوا
اسرار اللبان وتاريخ تجارته نحن بلاد ارض
اللبان المسم دمع الشجر يشهد لنا كل
الزمان ام قدمين بحر وبر واعلى وفان عين
الرباب شمع الموده والسمر يا سلاما لوح
الجمال
متعلم حضر ي
متعلم
حضر بين القرن السابع قبل الميلاد والقرن
الثاني ميلادي ازدهرت تجاره اللبان وكانت
عمان تصدره عبر طرق بحريه وبريه الى شتى
انحاء العالم المعروف انذاك نحن الان في
ميناء سمهرم الاثري ومنه كان يشحن اللبان
الى روما ومصر وبلاد الهند والسند في
التقرير التالي تعالوا لنعود بالزمن الى
القرن الاول لمرافقه قافله على درب اللبان
المحفوف بالمخاطر
والمشقه فجر هذا اليوم انطلقت قافله محمله
باكياس اللبان من اعالي جبال ظفار غدرت مع
طراوه اشعه الشمس الاولى على الطريق ضمت
الى قوافل اخرى خشيه من هجمات قطاع الطرق
والغز كلها محمله بحصاد شجر اللبان هذا
الصمغ اللبني اللون الذي تعتاش من بيعه
قبائل المنطقه منذ اجيال عند الغروب تدخل
القافله وقد فاق عدد جمالها المئه ميناء
سمهرم المعروف انذاك
بمسك قبل ايام وصل الى هذا الميناء
العامري بحاره من الهند ومعه هم القطن
والذره والتوابل والزيت
لمقاييس اللبان لن يمكثوا طويلا على هذه
السواحل يريدون العوده الى ديارهم قبل
حلول الشتاء معهم سيسافر اللبان الى بلاد
السندي والبنجاب وما بعدها قسم اخر من
الحموله سينقله بحاره عمانيون على مراكب
تحاذي الشاطئ ثم تفترق ليبحر بعضها شمالا
عبر مضق هرمز الى بابلا وفارس وجنوبا
باتجاه السواحل الافريقيه وغربا الى مصر
عبر البحر الاحمر فيما تسلك مراكب اخرى
الانهر باتجاه مدينه شبوه التي كانت تعتبر
اهم مركز لتجاره اللبان في المنطقه وهناك
ستفرض على اللبان اولى الضرائب قبل ان
تواصل هذه السلعه طريقها برا الى مارب
ونجران وصولا الى غزه وعلى طول الطريق برا
سيفرض حكام الصحراء ضرائب جديده على
اللبان في مملكه سبا ومعين وفي اراضي
الانباط والفينيقيين الذين كانوا ينقلون
اللبان بدورهم في البحر المتوسط الى بلاد
الاغريق والرومان وهكذا عندما كان اللبان
العماني يبلغ روما كان سعره اغلى من الذهب
ولا عجب في ان تكون هذه التجاره المربحه
قد اثارت طمع الكثيرين فمن اجل التحكم بها
دمرت الجيوش الاشوريه المدن الفينيقيه
وغزه في القرن الثامن قبل الميلاد بعد ان
كان الفينيقيون ينقلون مع الانباط الى
الاشوريين 3000 طن من اللبان سنويا ول
الاستحواذ على هذه التجاره في جنوب
الجزيره العربيه حصل الرومان مارب دون
جدوى في القرن الاول قبل الميلاد وقبلهم
بثلاثه قرون فشل الاغريق في كسر تحكم
الانباط بسوق اللبان وهكذا قبل اكثر من
4000 عام شكل درب اللبان جسرا للتواصل
والتنافس بين حضارات العالم القديم
القافله التي انطلقت من جبال ظفار هذا
الصباح تعود غدا الى ديارها لكن حبات
اللبان التي حملتها ستسافر بعيدا وتساهم
قبل الاتفاقيات الدوليه والمنظمات الامميه
في تعزيز تبادل السلع والثقافات بين
الشعوب تصعيد البخور من العادات المتاصله
لدى الشعوب العربيه للتعبير عن حراره
الترحيب وحفاوه الاستقبال لكن التبخير
وحده لا يفسر التهافت منذ القدم على
اقتناء اللبان ولو باسعار باهظه فما سر
هذه الحبه اللبنيه التي لاجلها تنافست امم
وحضرات
احرقه الاشوريون والفرس واليهود في
معابدهم واستخدمه المصريون القدامى في
طقوس التحنيط والرومان في مراسم التشييع
هو اللبان الذي تباهت في اقتنائه الحضارات
منذ القدم في جنوب الجزيره العربيه كانت
المعتقدات الشعبيه تقول ان لشجر اللبان
قدرات خارقه وكان من يعمل على حصاده يتبع
طقوسا روحانيه ض الارواح الشريره وارضاء
الجن فقبل البدء بتجريح شجر اللبان
لاستخراج صمغه كانت تتلى الصلوات والادعيه
ويصعد البخور ولو ان بعض الباحثين يعتقد
ان هذه الطقوس كان الغرض منها تخويف
اللصوص من سرقه حصاد شجر اللبان الثمين
وعن شجره اللباني كتب المؤرخ اليوناني
الشهير هيرودوت ان ثعابين مجنحه ص غيره
ومتعدده الالوان تحرس هذه الاشجار ويتدلى
عدد كبير منها فوق اغصانها ولا تبعد
الثعابين عن شجر اللبان الا رائحه
البخور اليوم لا تزال دور العباده تعبق
بروائح البخور من الكنائس المسيحيه الى
المعابد البوذيه ومقامات الائمه والاولياء
الصالحين لدى
المسلمين لكن اللبان بانبعاث بخوره العطر
لا يهدئ فقط الروح ويبسم اضطراباتها فقد
استخدم منذ القدم كمسكن للالام ومضاد
للالتهابات ولعلاج الحروق
والتقرحات ومنشط لجهاز المناعه فوائده
الصحيه اعترف بها باكرا الطب الشعبي
ولاحقا الادويه الحديثه حتى انه في
السنوات الاخيره اشف باحثون بريطانيون ان
حمض البخور بك اسد الذي نجده في اللبان
قادر على محاربه الخلايا السرطانيه
بفعاليه منذ الاف السنين والشعوب تؤمن بان
لحبه اللبان قدرات سحريه ومكانه مقدسه وها
هي الابحاث العلميه اليوم تكشف عن قدرات
جديده للبان في مداواه الروح والجسد
كما تعرفون اللبان او البخور هو في الاصل
صمغ بلوري يفرزه لحاء هذه الاشجار نحن
الان في محميه اشجار اللبان بوادي دوكا
بمحافظه ظفار جنوب سلطنه عمان ومعنا اليوم
ليحدثنا عن اسرار هذه الشجره الاستاذ احمد
بن عامر العوائد المشرف على محبيه اشجار
اللبان استاذ احمد مرحبا وشكرا على
استقبالنا مرحبا وحياكم الله شكرا نعرف ان
هذه الشجره لا تنبت الا في اماكن قليله
جدا في العالم لماذا يا ترى هل من عوامل
تربه او مناخ محدده لنموها سؤال وجيه جدا
طبعا هذه الاشجار لا تنمو في كثير من
الدول او في كثير من المناخات والسبب
الرئيسي هو المناخ له دور كبير حيث ان هذه
النوع من الاشجار تتاثر بالرياح الموسميه
القادمه من المحيط الهندي
وكذلك الهواء الجاف القادم من الربع
الخالي والمناطق الصحراويه
هذا ينتج عنه ظهور حزام من الاشجار اللبان
تمتد من شرق محافظ ظفار الى الحدود
اليمنيه في الغرب
[موسيقى]
تفضلوا
وما هي طريقه استخراج اللبان وهل تغيرت
على مر الزمن لم تتغير بطبيعه الحال طريقه
استخراج اللبان مدى الزمن فالطريقه
التقليديه تستخدم الى الان باستخدام
الادوات المحليه الصنع في البدايه طريقه
الاستخراج تسمى بالتوقيع وهي كشط القشره
الخارجيه للشجره لمسافه 5 سنتيمترات ثم
تترك لمده 25 الى 26 يوم وبعد 26 يوم يقوم
الجاني ايضا
بكشط نفس الجرح مره اخرى وتسمى السعفه
اللولى في السعفه اللولى تظهر يظهر اللبان
فيها اكثر من المرحله الاولى ثم تترك لمده
26 يوم اضافيه وتاتي المرحله الثالثه
والرابعه والخامسه والسادسه حتى والسابعه
وكل مرحله يكون فيها الادرار اكثر من
المرحله التي سبقتها طيب على سبيل المثال
كم كيلوغرام من اللبان يمكن ان تنتج هذه
الشجره هذهه الشجره تنتج ما يقارب 8
كيلوغرامات على مدى العام من ثمانيه الى
سبع ضربات استاذ احمد العوائد شكرا جزيلا
على كل هذه المعلومات وشكرا مجددا على
استقبالنا شكرا
[موسيقى]
جزيلا شلي معي شلي يا عوي شل شل مع شل يا
عوي شل هي سف
الملوك ش مع ياو منذ عه الاف عام عمانيون
يحصدون اللبان وحتى لو لم يعد اللبان
اليوم اغلى السلع في العالم الا انه لا
يزال يبث اجواء ايجابيه من الراحه
والانشراح على امل ان تكون هذه الحلقه قد
نالت اعجابكم اودعكم على ان ن القاكم في
حلقه مقبله من اسرار
عمان يا عو شل شل معي شل يا عو شل شل معي
شل يا عو شل
طلب الملوك هي شل مع الشل يا عوين شل هي
اسود اللبان يا عوين سل اسود اللبان يا
عوين شل
هيص واليونان شل مع شل يا عوي شل هي
المسرح بعيدي والطريق اسد المسرح بعيده
والطريق سرد حمول ثقله والدرب بعد حمول
ثقيله والدرب بعد ش يا ع ش